it is being called a game changer for
Ukraine Berlin agreeing to supply its
lever to tanks
speaking to reporters from a military
training facility in East Germany
defense minister Boris Pastorius is
pressed on when they will arrive in
countries
of the year
that's what we are going to do
I said at the end of at the end of March
I think is that in time because
ukrainians expect a Russian offensive to
be imminent all I know is that it is
earlier this week Germany approved the
delivery of hundreds of leopard 2 tanks
in EU arsenals to Kiev in the first
stage of the latest NATO push to send
more heavy weapons
what Ukrainian commanders say they need
along with more ammunition before the
winter thaw and an expected Russian
spring offensive
getting those Vehicles will improve
their ability to take ground but but I I
would be a little cautious about
assuming that with them they will
conquer the world the U.S is sending
dozens of its M1 Abrams tanks and the
uk-14 of its Challenger twos they will
add to hundreds of Russian t-72s already
in Ukrainian military service
Moscow seized the development as Western
countries becoming directly involved in
the war and one that will lead to what
it describes as permanent escalation
the success of tanks on land in European
conflicts has historically relied on air
support and that is exactly what
Ukraine's President says it needs next
long-range missiles more artillery and
crucially modern military aircraft if it
is to take back the Skies over Ukraine
is a former advisor to Russian President
Vladimir Putin and he says the tanks are
not a threat from Moscow
as a military force they had relatively
negligible but uh the problem is that by
sending tanks maybe countries are even
more openly involved in this war in this
conflict and that makes them potential
targets for iteration however I'm pretty
sure that eventually a Russia will
destroy Ukrainian military and the
country will be fully debnauthorized and
uh did not they're not not civilized I
mean their their
uh there will be finished or from the
Western Europe uh Ukraine is uh
ingredients are used as a cannon folder
and their leadership are basically
marionettes so we know that we are
fighting not ukrainians there I mean
though ukrainians are uh
uh are uh see the sacrifice but the West
which has been
expanding and de facto
preparing to attack Russia
openly and putting the military person
by expanding NATO
Russia decided to strike Opel the first
but it has been 25 years of expansion